what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I go over this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today if you want to be the ultimate
alpha male if you want to have women
come up to you left right center and say
you are so amazing and awesome get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
okay all right today's news guys we have
a lot to go over we have updates on the
Logan Paul case we have Anthony Anderson
being ordered to pay 20K a month
and we have women changing over time a
couple examples of that but guys um to
start I actually saw this on Instagram
okay the new generation of kids is like
actually insane
um we have an entire generation of kids
that are growing up on social media and
it's really interesting because if you
look at the stats like they're risky
behavior is actually going down
so the kids nowadays are less likely to
have a job less likely to have a license
less likely to have engaged in sexual
activities you know like this idea of
like these risky teenagers everything's
like getting moved to online and digital
and it's just like a really interesting
time to be alive and you wonder like
sometimes for the Amish right or
um but what you can really see is this
next generation of kids being influenced
by the media and I saw a um basically
one of those shows where if you disagree
with the statement you go sit like on
the chairs or whatever and there was a
young boy who was the only one in the
room that said that boys are stronger
than girls let's let's pull up the clip
bullies are stronger than girls
well physically like for the most part
in gender roles and stuff like that boys
are just supposed to be stronger they're
just a thing that happens they work out
of the gym and yeah girls certainly can
work out too if they want but again it's
more common for boys
can they disagree or a step forward
foreign
to say what gender like depends like
who's stronger it doesn't matter what
gender you are it matters who you are it
doesn't matter what you're born it
matters what you want to be you can be
referring to strength in so many ways
like physically emotionally where the
strength in your body is placed like it
all just depends and
there's just so many factors that go
into it I play volleyball and sometimes
we play the boys teams and we like you
know we crush them a couple times and it
feels so good you know so I don't
necessarily I don't agree with that oh
stop it I have played volleyball for 15
years
basketball too okay
and don't get me wrong sometimes you can
kind of compete sometimes if the men are
really unathletic you can beat them
oh but stop it by and large no no no no
no no no and maybe when they're younger
before the boys hit puberty
sure
it's closer the men are still stronger
and and this is the thing you see how
influenced these kids are by this woke
gender ideology that they clearly learn
in schools I think that's filmed in
California
where now we don't even know what a man
is and what a woman is
and you know we're telling them that
women somehow are are close to as strong
as men imagine thinking that oh my gosh
that's crazy volleyball
like stop I mean guys will literally hit
the 10 foot line and women I mean
they'll do it sometimes but gosh it is
not as common I actually sometimes will
play with the guys and I just get so
annoyed because I'm just not trying to
get hit in the face because you guys you
know I still play volleyball in England
and literally sometimes we do co-ed and
I hate it because I'm just not trying to
get hit
um and it's gotten so confusing and I
always talk about this how social media
becomes real life
um where 10 years ago when I went to
college it just seemed like a really
far-fetched thing that like you would
even meet a trans person you never would
um and then now I'm it's 10 years later
I live in London I'm in England
um and I played in a volleyball
tournament this spring and guess who's
there a team full of dudes okay so um as
you guys know
um Logan Paul and Dylan Dennis have a
fight scheduled October 14th and in
preparation for the fight Dylan danis
has been tweeting pictures of Logan
Paul's fiance with other men this has
included men that she's dated
um Talk Show skits that she's done and
just men that she's met at parties and
it's totaled that she has been pictured
with over 50 dudes
um and allegedly he has a picture that
is so crazy that he says it would end
the engagement
um and it's been confirmed by other
YouTubers that have allegedly seen the
picture that this picture is insane
however Dylan danis has been struck with
a lawsuit by Nina Agdal she alleges that
he hacked her Snapchat to which he has
responded and said that he has not
hacked her Snapchat and all of these
pictures were available online
um so you know this is Dylan danis's and
Logan Paul's responses to the lawsuit
he keeps talking about my fiance I'll
fight somebody else so I said okay I'll
stop I just post real pictures it's just
misconduct Dylan get the promotion that
I want to work with you because you're a
scumbag that's not my problem do you
have a pitch off yes do you have a
picture I swear I swear on anything so
so check this out I have a picture even
if you did which you don't you tell me
you didn't hold the Zone they're trying
to get the play pool you are admitting
on Twitter to Distributing and sending
an explicit image to people is already a
crime okay I got no money to show you I
dare you to okay yeah
okay
so Tristan Tate weighs in he says for
everybody talking about going too far
when hyping a fight let's remember
Muhammad Ali had his religion and name
disrespected Mike Tyson said he wanted
to eat lennox's children Ali called
Fraser and Uncle Tom nobody sued posting
images from Google get over it you know
um and going back and forth on this I
actually I agree with Dylan you know I I
understand that Logan is disrespected
okay fine I mean this is supposed to be
a fight you know I I see don't don't do
UFC don't do this stuff if if you can't
deal with what comes with it and
unfortunately what comes with it is a
ton of trash talking I don't get it
it's not really my thing but you know
the guys that sign up for this they know
that's what comes with it and I think I
really do think Tristan had a point like
you know if some Fighters are getting
their religion disrespected they're
being called things that are racist what
why is your fiance off limits you know
one guy had his ear bit off of
I mean this is a world I'm not from I
don't really get it but I mean I I mean
the way it is now Logan could legally
beat him up for 18 minutes straight
instead and he's gonna Sue and why don't
they just Sue after the fight that's
what I don't get so um last week I was
on Piers Morgan and when I was on Pierce
Morgan I was asked to give my take on
the Russell Brand situation I mean this
is just my opinion from the information
that I know well and you're telling me
that a guy that has women throwing
themselves at him 24 7 had to rape
somebody that doesn't make sense to me
I don't think I don't think you can make
the leap but that couldn't happen I
didn't say it couldn't I'd say it's very
unlikely like it's Elon Musk is he gonna
rob a bank probably not I think it's
certainly less likely but he could do it
now I believe that Russell Brand is
innocent and the reason I believe
Russell Brand is innocent is I think
that the woman has every incentive to
lie and the man has zero incentive to
lie
um typically men that are having sex
thrown at them 24 7 do not have to rape
someone for sex but usually broke
post-wall women
need money
I I mean money and attention they're
missing so it seems like she has every
incentive to lie
um and do the wrong thing where the
woman does it and my question is if all
of these women are coming out with
assault allegations then why aren't they
all public why was there no police
report and at the end of the day until I
see
a police report I I just don't buy it
you know and people want to say she was
16. I get it you might not like it but
it's legal and as long as it's legal um
that's not coercion that's not grooming
that's that's legal
after I went on Piers Morgan
um my assistant actually sent me this
article that was written about me
apparently
the female quote unquote the female
Andrew Tate gives the most toxic support
to Russell Brand yet
oh there's me
I mean I had a cute outfit that day I'm
not even mad they picked that picture
this article discusses how several
influential figures including Elon Musk
Andrew Tay Alex Jones Ben Shapiro and
Tucker Carlson have publicly supported
the comedian Russell Brand who faces
allegations he vehemently denies the
author expresses concern about the
arguments made by Pearl Davis known as
the female Andrew Tate Davis questions
why a rich and famous man who would need
to commit sexual assault and draws an
analogy to being accused of bank robbery
as a billionaire
this article highlights that such
arguments suggesting attractive or
successful men have no reason to commit
sexual assault have been used to
discredit allegations against predators
it references a 2018 piece by safe
Horizon a Victim Assistance charity that
explores the Persistence of the myth
that attractive men don't have to rape I
mean I didn't say they didn't have to I
said it was unlikely and the other thing
okay so you want me
to take seriously
an organization that makes money through
Victim Assistance like they have an
incentive for there to be more victims
the article closes by reiterating
Russell Brand's denial of the
accusations and provides contact
information of support for organizations
and those affected by rape and sexual
abuse Pearl Davis is portrayed as a
supporter of Russell Brand who employs
questionable reasoning in defending him
echoing the problematic notion that
successful individuals would not engage
in sexual assault the article emphasizes
the potential harm of such arguments and
the need for awareness and support for
survivors of abuse is the question wrong
like you know what's so funny they gave
me this word salad
uh they didn't tell me where I'm wrong
our Rich successful men not less likely
to rape are men that have unlimited sex
not less likely to rape I didn't say
they couldn't do it I didn't say was
impossible but wouldn't you think
it's maybe less likely
Maybe
am I crazy for thinking this
I've
look I I haven't seen good enough
evidence that indicates that he's guilty
if you show me the evidence
I might change my opinion but you can
only do this so many times you know
they've called Andrew Tate a human
trafficker they have canceled
comedian after comedian
journalist after journalists saying that
they did things they didn't do with very
little to no proof
and after a while your your Spidey
senses kind of start to go on
and you're just less likely to believe
it you know
um I I say show me the evidence and I'll
change my opinion I've been going
getting into sort of a debate on Twitter
that I actually think it's irresponsible
to tell men to get married in 2023 I
think it's irresponsible
um I think if you're going to tell men
to get married you need to warn them of
the risk and the risk is it doesn't
matter who you marry it doesn't matter
how great of a man that you are
if a woman feels like leaving
unfortunately the government and the
state will back her up and even a good
Christian woman who prays can get the
wrong group of friends start watching
the wrong Media or just feel a certain
way and the state will legally allow her
to bankrupt you
to take your children
and to falsely accuse you of abuse and
rape and that is the risk for a lot of
men and that is a death sentence to a
lot of men now I don't say this because
I hate marriage in fact I think marriage
is a beautiful thing I think when done
correctly marriage is amazing it is the
building block of society
however marriage in 2023 is not marriage
the average marriage is seven years
women get custody 90 of the time most
alimony and child support payments go to
women the majority of women
are in debt women make 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions indicating
that women really run the majority of
households
um and so what I hear and what I would
call a bit of a cope is just find a good
woman and marry Young
well here I have a guy who decided to do
just that Anthony Anderson married his
college sweetheart and is now ordered to
pay his ex-wife twenty thousand dollars
a month and she gets to keep both houses
Anthony Anderson will Fork over twenty
thousand dollars every month to his
ex-wife Alvina Stewart her his divorce
judgment but he could be paying even
more depending on how his career is
going according to the documents
obtained by TMZ Anthony will pay the 20K
base amount and that number will go up
if his gross annual earnings go over 2
million if that's the case he'll pay an
additional 20 of his income
in other words the more Anthony makes
the more he's got a shell out to Alvina
that's how spousal support works but
he's not walking out of the marriage
empty-handed
um what did this woman do to deserve
twenty thousand a month
I know how hard it is to make that you
guys likely know how hard it is to make
that absurd amount of money and this
woman had sex with him for a prolonged
period of time and now is rewarded with
two houses and 20 000 a month
for breaking up a marriage
what on Earth could she do to deserve
that I don't even think if he cheated
that she would deserve that to be honest
I don't think there's much he could do
to deserve it she could have been a
perfect wife for 20 years but 20 000 a
month is absolutely insane and he did
what a lot of people do they get married
young now again I think marriage is a
beautiful thing I hope everybody can
have a wife and kids but the truth of
the matter is when women get power we
tend to abuse it I I see no indication
that women are getting less power and I
see no indication that women will not
abuse the power they have I ask you the
question if the men between the ages of
50 to 80 a large portion got screwed
over in divorce if the men between 40 to
50 a large portion got screwed over in
divorce if the men under 40
are on track to be screwed over in
divorce what would be different about
the next group of men if there was a
school
where 10 of the students died which mind
you this is death to a lot of men many
men commit suicide after this situation
because their entire Community thinks
they're an abuser they are in debt a lot
of them a lot of them can't afford the
child support payments that they have to
pay many lose their jobs because of the
stress and many of them have kids that
hate them because of what the mother has
said about them so at that point they
have no Legacy God knows who's going to
be raising the kids they maybe get to
see their kids twice a month and if you
sent someone to a school
where five ten percent of the students
died with no warning that would be
pretty irresponsible right but yet we
expect men to sign up for marriage one
with no warning two with no backup plan
and three just expecting everything to
turn out okay instead of preparing for
the worst they say just go find a woman
who prays and as nice as that sounds as
much as I want to believe that I I see
very little evidence that the women that
identify as Catholic and Christian
are that much better when I look at
divorce rates it seems to be roughly
at the lowest I've seen 20 percent but
let's say
it's five percent ten percent isn't that
a big enough percentage that men should
be extremely cautious when it comes to
marriage yet you still see conservative
personalities
saying to just blindly Mary young going
go get married you're not you're not a
real man if you don't get married well
by this logic Jesus isn't a real man and
let's see what the comments say when
talking about this story so what's the
point of getting married if I gotta pay
for my ex after a divorce Jade says
there's no point and this is the
conclusion that many men are going to
come to it doesn't matter what I say it
doesn't matter what any other red pill
or conservative commentator says you
could say what sounds nice and it's much
easier it's much easier to have a nice
cell where you can sound good to
everybody and do the marriage and family
Trope but is it really nice when you're
sending at least we can agree five to
ten percent of men onto basically
suicide really a suicide mission you
know all you're doing is sending the
next generation of men to the cleaners
which is why it's so important that we
change and reform divorce laws this
needs to be the number one thing that
all political commentary haters are
talking about this needs to be the
number one agenda to politicians the
truth of the matter is men have more
power than they realize and they think
men are the ones paying for everything
men pay the majority of the taxes they
do the majority of the hard jobs
politicians need men to run society and
men need to start demanding from
politicians that they change some of
these policies and make them more fair
now I don't have all the answers I don't
know if that means eliminating no fault
divorce
um I've toyed around with that idea it
could mean giving men automatic custody
of children it could mean making some of
the alimony and child support payments
more fair or even getting rid of them
all together
um I'm open to suggestions maybe it's
something the right and the left can
come together on but the point of the
matter is
the way that we're doing marriage today
is not marriage and it's not fair to men
and until we make it more fair I will
never shame a guy for not wanting to
sign up in fact I would say to be
extremely cautious when signing up for
that system
and the
pushback I always get is Pearl don't you
want to get married well I think most
women have every incentive to want to
get married
I I think marriage is a good thing for
women but it's a terrible thing for men
in 2023. I don't say this with a happy
heart I I don't say this because I'm
happy about it I'm a Catholic and I do
believe in the sanctity of marriage but
until the institutions change I see no
indication that the women are going to
get better and do the right thing
so knowing that the women are getting
worse and there's going to be more and
more women that do the wrong thing isn't
it a little bit irresponsible to push
men into a system that really them
excuse my language
um and and here's the thing I think that
this power has actually made women worse
it has made us ungodly worse as a
collective and you see this and I always
say the media becomes real life soon
enough so you might see a clip here or
there and think those are just crazy
ladies well they're crazy ladies until
the crazy ladies start coming out to the
suburbs until the crazy ladies start
coming out to the country they go to
school with your kids and until these
systems change
really you're just gonna keep seeing
more and more of the craziness so
there's a woman that's going viral I
think this clip is a couple years old
but I wanted to show you something that
we can learn from it there's a woman
that accuses a man of cheating and the
other woman owns up to lying let's play
the clip what is like respectful in a
relationship trusting a person and not
paying somebody to see if they would
cheat but it happened not true you went
on a date with this girl it wasn't a
date she literally told me that you took
her out to eat oh yeah and you guys
hooked up you can't sit here and deny
that I am denying because it's not true
okay sure she's a client and after we
were working out we got food which was
across the street that's not what she
told me that's what I'm telling you guys
had sex I'm telling you we did it so are
you saying she's lying I'm saying she's
lying let's find out from her
Paula can you tell him what you told me
so I pretty much told her
that took me to this really fancy
restaurant and afterwards we went back
to my place and hooked up and that he
came on to you in the car and you guys
are kissing yes yeah see why would you
sit here and lie I lied because so you
weren't telling the truth
I didn't think that she deserved you so
I lied oh my God
and look so this is why I just think
that women shouldn't really worry about
cheating I think if a guy's gonna cheat
he's gonna cheat if he's not he's not I
don't really think if a guy cheats that
means he doesn't love you I think men
will have sex with anything there's a
reason that we have those phrases but
what you get
um with women being told they need to
worry about cheating all the time where
we're just constantly pandered to and
told the men are these dogs they're
always gonna be up to nonsense as you
have women doing crazier and crazier
things to catch men cheating baiting men
into cheating and honestly I think if
you bait a guy into cheating you
honestly deserve to get cheated on sorry
I know they're gonna clip out whatever
don't care
um and I thought this is especially
hilarious because
oh because that other girl she kind of
clocked on but that this was insane it's
actually insane to get a girl to try to
get your guy to cheat like ladies this
is not a normal behavior uh feminine
women don't look for problems feminine
women don't try to create chaos you know
they they would rather just stay out of
all of that I wanted to again kind of
going back to the theme that women do
change over time women kind of this
Society has just made us like absolutely
insane
um I wanted to use a example of a man
that married his high school sweetheart
okay his high school sweetheart that was
a Christian good woman
so Steph Curry and Aisha Curry
um got married their High School
sweethearts and Aisha Curry used to be
this like picture-perfect wife right and
I remember being like a Drake song that
said he wanted a girl like Aisha because
she was one of the few women that
weren't naked like she she was covered
up she was conservative she was
Christian and it's just weird the last
couple of years she's completely gone
off the rails so in 2015 she had a tweet
that said just looking at the latest
fashion trends I'll take classy over
trendy any day of the week Saturday
night Insight so you know she was
bragging that she wasn't about this
sexualization of women in society and
what I see I kind of see this trend
where like women will when they're in
their younger 20s will be a little bit
well I mean God I see it both ways but
one Trend that I see sometimes from the
tradcon chicks is when they're younger
they'll be super covered up and then
it's like when their face kind of starts
to go they like run into the gym and
then they're trying to in their late 20s
early 30s they're trying to like fix the
body to get that attention that they're
losing because I I mean everyone every
chick loses attention right later 20s
30s whatever
um and now in 2023 so this is eight
years later let's let's look at this
uh she she's talking about classiness
and now she's butt naked now eight years
later there's rumors they're in an open
marriage
um there's clips of her that have gone
viral saying that she is jealous of the
attention that her husband gets like
these are these are case studies guys
and you know if if
you're telling me Steph Curry
a world-renowned basketball player Rich
um I have a hard time believing that
he's really doing anything that bad in
the marriage that wrong Christian guy
that all the women want he can't even
control his wife that is the level of
wives in this Society because social
media I mean I think women would just
have a tendency towards crazy but social
media has just exaggerated it and it
rewards bad behavior it rewards taking
off your clothes and it's to the point
where sometimes you'll have a good
Christian woman and she'll go crazy and
that's what tried con sometimes
fundamentally do not understand about
women is women kind of go with the group
and this idea that you're going to find
some woman that's special and different
than all the rest you know some women
are higher risk some women are lower
risk
but all women have the same Hardware
all women have the same programming the
same software some women aren't don't go
as off the rails but any woman can go
completely off the rails at any time and
we've seen it over and over again where
you know Lolo Jones she was a good
Christian woman when she was younger now
she's going off the rails when she's
older like we see this time and time
again the effects of extreme attention
on women
and in 2023 you're probably not going to
Shield your chick from social media
you're probably not going to Shield your
chick from the entire world so the only
thing you can really do is do the best
you can and pray
hope for the best but expect the worst
and I and I have no problem with men
choosing marriage family and
relationships I actually it makes you
know there's something about going to a
wedding there's something about like you
know this beautiful Union between a man
and a woman you know as a Catholic like
I've seen it I've seen real love I've
seen people that have a genuine marriage
genuine relationship and have done
awesome things but
I don't sell dreams on this channel like
a lot of you if I sold you this dream I
would be just as bad as Steve Harvey yes
a lot of these commentators are just as
bad as Steve Harvey because they're
selling you the exception when most
people are the rule and the truth of the
matter is half of relationships fail
marriage is a terrible reputation
um so out of the relationships that make
it I would say half of those are utterly
miserable
um so you're more likely to fail than
succeed and expect to be the rule but
hope you're not
and that's my commentary so you know I I
don't say this with a happy heart but
Society just seems to be going one way I
hope we can figure out a way to turn it
back the other but I see no indication
that women are going to get less
I see no indication that we're going to
be married longer
and I I don't see much indication that
families are really gonna come together
again but let me know what you guys
think comments like the video let's get
to 2 000 likes get yourself a woman
shouldn't vote t-shirt today I'll talk
to you next time